we're going to talk about the
operational amplifier or op amp for
short and this is the workhorse of all
analog electronics the operational
amplifier it's a type of amplifier an
amplifier is is anything that you put an
electronic signal end and you get out a
larger version of the signal so this
would be an amplifier with some sort of
gain and if I put a signal X in here
usually a voltage or a current then the
signal that comes out here is a times X
and that's what we mean by amplification
and a signal that I've shown here is X
is anything that we're interested in it
could be a voltage or a current and when
we put it through an amplifier we get a
larger version of it so this is a really
common activity in electronic design now
when we talk specifically about an
operational amplifier the symbol for
that we use for an operational amplifier
is a triangle and it has two inputs one
is the plus input one is the minus input
and it has an output and it also has two
power supplies to it there's a some sort
of plus voltage it goes into it and some
sort of minus voltage so this is the
abstract symbol for an op-amp so when we
say the word op-amp we have some
specific properties in mind one is op
amps have high gain so in this case the
the gain usually with the symbol a is
something like ten to the fifth to ten
to the sixth really really high
another thing we think about when we
talk about op amps is that they're used
for feedback circuits and we'll talk
about feedback in the next couple of
videos and what that means but that's
the application that we use op amps for
and the third thing that's distinctive
about op amps is that they have this
this kind of input this kind of input
here is referred to as a differential
input so an op-amp usually has
differential inputs and that's as
opposed to something we call a single
ended input which will be just one wire
and what a differential input means it
says we have we can label the voltages
here we'll call this V out we'll call
this V plus and we'll call this input V
minus and differential input means that
V out equals the gain times V plus minus
V minus so the output signal here is
proportional to the difference in the
voltage between these two signals here
so I want to make a plot of this
equation right here just so we get a
good idea of what it looks like
and the axes here are V in and V out
where VN specifically equals V plus
minus V minus V plus minus V minus
that's the input signal to the op-amp
and we're going to apply the gain factor
to it to get V out so that'll look like
like this something like this is going
to be a very steep line and the slope of
that line the slope of this line is a so
the slope is going to be 10 to the 5th
or 10 to the 6 something like that very
very vertical now one of the properties
of this is that V out cannot go above or
below its power supply voltages so on
this plot here that's called saturation
if V out gets up to V Plus we say it's
saturates and looks like this it goes
flat basically here and here where this
voltage value here is minus the power
supply and this voltage right here is
the positive power supply but over this
range here over this range in here
between those two points it's quite
linear
it goes through zero and we this is
where we use it most of the time so now
I want to talk a little bit more detail
about what this symbol means here and
what's inside it and how it's actually
connected up in a circuit
so we talked about the voltage behavior
of an op-amp this is V Plus V minus and
V out there's one thing more that we
need to know and that is the current
this current right here and this current
right here for an op-amp an ideal op-amp
is zero no current flows in here so this
op-amp is just sensing the voltages at
these points but no current flows in so
this is the second key property of an
op-amp the first one is the voltage
behavior V out equals the gain times V
plus minus V minus another way we can
write this is V out equals a times V n
where V end-of-course equals V plus
minus V minus so these are the these are
the two electrical properties that are
going to allow us to analyze these
circuits and the analyzing the circuits
is actually going to be pretty simple so
you're probably wondering like what is
inside here what's going on inside here
so what's inside here is somewhere
between 20 and 50 or so transistors and
resistors sometimes capacitors these are
really complex designs and for right now
if we just concentrate on the two
properties that we have here we'll be
able to use these circuits even without
understanding exactly what's inside
suffice to say it's a differential
amplifier with really high gain and with
just that knowledge we can work out how
these circuits work so let me do a
couple of more details on how this thing
is actually hooked up so we have a plus
terminal and a minus terminal there's
more terminals on this there's a power
supply like this that's plus big V and
there has to be a minus supply typically
a - supply - V and let me a ground pin
to be a ground node on here like that
and when this is in a used in a circuit
they'll be over to the side there'll be
two power supplies and this will be 12
volts a 12 volts
volts is a real typical value and
there'll be another one and this is a
plus 12 volt supply as well and they'll
be connected together and this node
right between them will be their ground
node that's the voltage reference and
these two guys will be hooked up like
that the two power supplies will be
hooked up this way so with respect to
ground this node is at minus 12 volts
and this node from ground is at plus 12
volts and ground is right in the middle
and when we measure V out we'll measure
it with respect to this ground node so
this is the voltage where we measure
plus or minus V out right there and what
we're going to do is we're going to
assume that all of this stuff is always
hooked up and we're just going to use an
even simpler symbol
just the three terminals like that and
you'll know that all the rest of the
power supply is hooked up that way and
the thing to keep in mind is there's a
large - voltage there's a large plus
voltage and the ground level the ground
node is right in between so positive
voltage is high on the page negative
voltage is low on the page and V out can
go both positive and negative around
ground
so that's your voltage framework to keep
in your head
and the op-amp that we've been looking
at has a symbol like this and we know
that V out equals some huge gain times V
plus minus V minus so this is a
differential input here's V plus here's
V minus one way I think about this is is
to look at the way a change in voltage
on the input modifies the output I mean
let me label V out here so if there's a
change on the input say V plus goes this
way because it's a plus sign that means
that V out goes this way now if I change
it over to V minus V minus is on the
negative input if V minus goes up then
the out goes down so that's the
inverting it's called the inverting
input and this is called the
non-inverting input so on the
non-inverting input up goes up and on
the inverting input if you go up on the
inverting input you go in the opposite
direction on the output let's say that
the positive input the non-inverting
input went down this time and that means
what that means that V out will go down
and just do the same thing over here I'm
going to run out of colors let's do the
same thing for the inverting input
if the inverting input goes down what
does the what does the output do it goes
up it goes in the opposite direction
that's a way to think about the symbol
when you see it on a schematic page is
how do these signals translate through
the device positive non-inverting
signals go in the same direction
inverting signals go in the opposite
directions okay and here's one final
trick I want to share with you some to
be aware of you're going to see a symbol
like this on a page the same op-amp it's
the same op-amp but it's written on the
page with a negative with the inverting
symbol on the top and the non-inverting
symbol on the bottom so as you look at a
schematic that has an op-amp in it one
of the first things you want to do is
just glance and see what order these
symbols are in or is it does it look
like that or does it look like that and
keep that in mind as you're reading the
circuit and trying to understand what it
does ok let's move on and build
something with our op-amp